As we said at the outside
of this course,
one of the promises of the adoption
of digital records by providers and
patients would be the availability of
huge quantities of new data from which
analysis could yield insights into how
to diagnose and treat patients better.
And even how to improve our
system of care delivery.
You've now seen early
examples of each of these.
There are still problems
with the data itself.
It is often noisy,
inconsistent, or even wrong.
Some patients may have
a rich data set for
a particular clinical concept,
while others may have no data at all.
The interoperability problems we've
stressed throughout the course
are still an impediment.
Finally, as we discussed with
Don Detmer, we may have gone too far
with patient privacy and
made it too hard to obtain the data
that could make a valuable contribution
to health and healthcare delivery.
The solutions are ahead of us.
And it will continue to assure that
health informatics will be an exciting
and dynamic field for years to come.